when occupied West Bank town of hadron
right now where classes have just broken
out this is supposed to be Cape Town to
Maine damn it's been over a week since
hurricane Harvey hit these water
protectors have run over the hill to the
machinery over there to cross over
they're calling you a racist how to
respond to that
[Music]
occupation soldiers telling us not to
rock Wow guys this is a crazy scene
taking place right now in Northwest UT
on Inauguration Day
[Music]
I'm standing at one of the most heavily
militarized borders in the world this is
a rock wall Zuckerberg built around his
700 acre property
hundreds of refugees have gotten off and
they're about to walk through the
Austrian border we're gonna go with them
that's not a popular position to take it
around cause it's risky
imagine if Muslim Americans took up arms
and protested the federal government
what would the response have been
he said you're ready to fight tonight
yes we're actively lobbying your
congressman right now to support Israel
does that mean that you guys are armed
but he'll use your gun in an evening one
must pay for absolutely so footing why
are they targeting you cuz I'm black and
I'm an over to D yeah yeah yeah better
MMA you say so about the water will be
faced in 2035 Wow you see all this taro
and stuff we eat this stuff this is all
food right here
[Music]